okay well you clearly don't care so why
don't you sleeve I would like to stay
this pertains to me I would like you to
leave why don't you go outside take a
shot of insulin and have a nap okay why
do you always assume I have diabetes you
have a glass of apple juice and tell me
that you don't have diabetes okay all
right see just the noise you made when
you stood up I could this guy doesn't
just want to win you know he wants to
barrier he wants to humiliate you he
wants to prove I'm just gonna take I'm
like a quarter of the way through hey if
saber truly cared about a long-term
well-being they would set up handy
sanitizing stations hold up
what's a handy sanitizing station full
of dirt okay you understand the more we
expose ourselves to germs the stronger
[Laughter]
attend the tale of Sweeney Todd he can't
shoot
hey you yeah your biggest client on the
phone you don't really toss the know try
to destroy the old ways Gabe I will not
let you do it we're gonna go outside and
I guarantee you did you just SMS text
message me I just came from the museum
where I saw an exhibit hey did you MMS
text message me I just came from the
museum where a heist
return to sender
don't make any pre-fire you you wouldn't
dare oh man and when I get promoted
you're full fired if you get promoted ah
don't make me pre fire you you wouldn't
dare your pre fired and when I'm
promoted you're full fire if you're
promoted I'm working on an English
character would you mind
it's called Reginald poof down and sorry
might I forgot make me snorted cream do
you want your life to be better or worse
we're to say the same get out of my way
Danny look at me we don't recycle
we don't why have I been separating
trash into whites and colors could you
please show them into a conference room
be I'll be right with you
the pharmaceutical meetings should be
able to move you know they should be
able to accommodate us I thought he was
gonna show us
from being she took him with him she was
talking to the cameraman
camera lady leader yet don't look at me
I still want to quit but if I quit we'll
all quit it'll be anarchy I still want
to quit but if I quit
we'll all quit I still want to quit but
if I quit we'll all quit it'll work that
guy we're looking for him which way did
he go
this way this way this way that guy when
he leave which way did he go look for
him we looking for him
he went that way we're looking for him
which way did he go who knows this way
this way this way this way I don't know
which way the mall is corrupt
Mali's evil their appearances like gym
that is so inappropriate
you got a sec - chow absolutely get
these done out out
hello hey here to talk about whoops oh
cool
yes definitely as long as you're here to
tell me I'm a billionaire here on your
way man
on your way oh oh no it's great I love
working at dunder-mifflin Taliban branch
bloop no it's great
ooh oh no it's great hello we're gonna
Dunder Mifflin's out up in Brisbane we
have 3 SEC's for heavy petting closets
one masturbation closet does anyone have
a problem with that
yes closet five three heavy padding
closets one masturbation closet and one
gay clowns oh absolutely yes I don't
know problem everybody happy for the
glory holes glory hole
[Laughter]
we actually love musical theater we
actually love musical theater the great
thing okay
who can tell me oh I should get the
accident report binder I've never used
that gun phone Toby get back in here
right now sure you don't have the action
report on this great group back there to
Holly and Mindy
you